Amsterdam has this infamous reputation around the world...
...for being a little quirky and a little bit edgy,...
...and it definitely lives up to all of that.
That's what gives it its charm.
This is an absolutely beautiful city...
...and it's even better when you see it on the seat of a bike,...
...nice and slow so you can check out everything.
I love this boat, it's just covered with windows.
You can see all around you.
All through the canals, the sun is starting to set.
The buildings look absolutely beautiful.
And I now understand why they're calling this a romantic dinner cruise.
This place is huge.
There's over 80 acres of flowers here and over 2,000 varieties of tulips.
And right now we're here at the Van Gogh Museum in Amsterdam,...
...and we're looking at over 200 pieces of artwork...
...that he has done over his lifetime.